à
la fête de quartier de tétreaultville à
montréal on déambule on mange rien ne
laisse présager que nous sommes à
quelques heures d'une campagne
électorale
sauf peut-être l'omniprésence des
candidats des cinq principaux partis
allez vous suivre les élections qui
débute demain non pour bien bien bien
bien tranquillement pour voir ce que
chacun a apporté parce que là on entend
plein de la femme on n'est jamais déçu
oui je suis ce que ce soit d'un bord ou
de l'autre je suis au dessus donc j'y
crois plus le québec vivra sa deuxième
élection provinciale à date fixe depuis
des semaines on entend des annonces des
publicités partisanes
nous allons commencer plus tôt avait pas
de différence les électeurs
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir garder leurs
intérêts des policiers vont devoir
travailler fort le plus grand risque
pour les partis politiques c'est le
désintérêt face à la domination de la
caq dans les sondages tout le monde y
compris françois legault a intérêt à ce
que les gens se préoccupent de cette
élection là ne serait ce que pour
françois legault de faire sortir le vote
l'acq acq org en huit circonscriptions
par très peu de voix pour attirer leur
attention il faudra discuter d'enjeux
qui les préoccupent j'ai envie
d'entendre par une écologie c'est sur
l'environnement économique
konami premier prochaine pandémie
au-delà des enjeux
la population devrait s'intéresser à
cette élection potentiellement
historique
le québec pourrait se retrouver en
régimes de parti dominant selon cet
expert ce que tous les autres partis
d'opposition québec se retrouve en bas
de 26 ans ce qui fait que la carte des
minerais comme roi et maître dans le
système policier
une situation qui ne s'est vu qu'une
seule fois dans l'histoire de la
province en 1919 ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal